coronavirus spreads as the stock market
tanks the Trump administration calls for
calm as panic accelerates and Bernie
Sanders but Sanders struggles to stop
Joe Biden's momentum I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show this show
is sponsored by expressvpn stop putting
your online data at risk stop it right
now get protected an expressive VPN calm
slash Ben well you may have noticed this
morning that the stock market took an
absolute beating an absolute pounding
it's been taking a pounding for the last
week over coronavirus over Saudi oil war
we'll get to all of that in a second but
this might be a good time to think about
hey maybe I should invest in something
solid something real maybe something
like precious metals you've been
noticing the market yeah I've been
noticing the market too just like every
other person in the United States Birch
gold my friends go talk to British gold
right now what now like yesterday if you
have not yet taken the first step of
requesting a free information kit on
gold you should know this is not a
complicated process for you Birch gold
will go to work and make things super
simple they'll have a conversation with
you you can determine if precious metals
make sense for you there's no obligation
you have nothing to lose to take that
first step
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau right now would be a
great time to notice that maybe that is
versification into precious metals might
be something you want to think about
considering the state of the stock
market and the volatility that is likely
to last at this point I would say
probably four months do not wait until
the market drops more to protect your
hard-earned savings text Ben - 47 47 47
today - see how simple and
straightforward the move can be for you
again that's Ben - 47 47 47 my friends
at Birch gold that the people I trust
with precious metals investing and now
would be a good time yesterday would be
a great time to think about diversifying
techs Ben - 47 47 47 - ask all your
questions about investing in precious
metals with my friends at Birch gold all
right so feeling the panic are you
everybody is feeling a little bit
panicked after the last week and a half
and it is important to note that what is
happening right now is based on shortage
of information that's really all that's
happening we don't know death rates we
don't know infection rates when it comes
to coronavirus and this is leading
people I think reasonably to be very
afraid
now I think that panic and doing things
that make no sense like stocking up on
vast quantities of toilet paper or going
out and buying medical masks like stuff
that's ineffective going out and buying
water bottles guys there's not gonna be
a cut off of your water supply you're
gonna be able to turn on your tap
water's gonna come out you know that
kind of stuff is very silly with that
said a discombobulated global
response in a a patchwork response from
various local communities I mean la had
an LA Marathon yesterday at the same
time you're seeing Democrats in the
United States claim the president Trump
is watching the response and he should
be doing more
you have Democrat cities like Seattle
Seattle had comic-con like last weekend
with a hundred thousand people in an
outbreak Center the LA Marathon took
place yesterday in Los Angeles with like
tens of thousands of people running
around together
okay so there's been no coordinated
response people don't know what the
rules of the road are people don't know
how dangerous coronavirus actually is we
don't know how many people are dying
I've suggested that we can kind of look
at the stats and determine that it's not
a grave threat to people particularly
who are very young there have been no
reported deaths of kids under the age of
nine the death rates tend to go up
fairly precipitously once you hit the
age of sixty once you hit the age of
eighty they go really precipitously if
you have a secondary health condition or
if you are elderly then coronavirus is a
real threat this is particularly true if
you're in a nursing home or it's very
easy to transmit coronavirus and where
again you have a very vulnerable patient
population but because we are watching
these very outsized responses which may
or may not be a good idea in places like
Italy in in places like China in places
like Israel we look at other countries
and we see that they're taking these
very outsized responses it's difficult
to make the claim that a global panic
over coronavirus is driven by President
Trump so the media today are trying to
blame President Trump for everything
that is going on President Trump is not
helping the situation by being not a a
supremely I would say Placid leader you
know in these times having the President
of the United States online tweeting
about media coverage of coronavirus is
really not useful you want a calming
presence in the Oval Office somebody who
feels like there's a plan somebody who
feels like they're in control and
honestly on a political level the
president is making a fairly large
mistake politically and not overreacting
what I mean by that is when people are
feeling a real threat going out there
and being like everything's fine our
response is perfect the vaccines and
development everything's good our
testings are our testing procedures
we're great
our testing procedures were not great in
the initial stages the tests failed one
of the reasons we have a panic on our
hands in the United States is because
people don't have any access to
information right the fact is that
because a lot of the early coronavirus
testing kits failed we don't know who
has coronavirus and who does not
in the United States which is why we've
ended up with this sort of bizarre
miasmatic feeling that anybody could
have it when in reality very few people
in the United States have actually been
diagnosed with coronavirus with all that
said you know this would be a time as
we're gonna discuss in a little while
for the President of the United States
in Congress to seriously consider
measures like trying to coordinate a
federal state and local response in
terms of event planning right what what
size of events should should go forward
what should the state not allow to go
forward in terms of size of event and
you're seeing a lot of local communities
taking the lead in all of this and I'm
most aware of my local Jewish community
I know that major poram events right
tonight is poram which is a major Jewish
gathering big parties happening all over
the world I know that in the Jewish
community in Los Angeles major events
are being canceled like poram carnivals
are being canceled I know that at
schools do local Jewish schools they are
there now testing kids who are walking
in the door they're giving them
temperature tests and if they are above
a certain temperature they're sending
them home for whatever good that is so
people on the local level across the
country are taking voluntary steps to
try and mitigate the effects of this
virus obviously best advice is still
best advice if you got a COFF COFF in
your sleeve Koff into a napkin if you
got to touch your face right now to
touch your eyes trying to touch your
mouth try not touch your nose I know
it's difficult if you're gonna you
should be washing your hands as much as
possible especially after you go to the
restroom you should that anyway but when
you go to a new place when you go to
work first thing you should do you
should go wash your hands you should
sing yourself happy birthday twice not
the Stevie Wonder version that'll take
it like 14 minutes like the actual short
version of happy birthday using the ABC
song to yourself right these are all the
pieces of advice that everybody is
giving and they're good pieces of advice
social distancing is something that
people are taking into account at this
point which frankly I'm comfortable with
I don't like being within a certain
within a certain distance of other human
beings so you know being within try to
be without outside of like two and a
half feet three feet of somebody
handshaking apparently is bad because
you can transmit germs that way instead
go for like a fist bump or an elbow bump
or something if you're gonna greet sorry
these are all the steps that we can take
but in the absence of information it's
hard not to feel panicked because the
normal human response to lack of
information is obviously going to be
fear and protection right the amygdala
the fear center of your brain is going
to respond and when the media coverage
is so blanket this way it is very
difficult not to feel caught up in it
and that's why
you're seeing in the markets today if
the media during flu season covered flu
wall-to-wall if all you got during flu
season was flu outbreak here flu
outbreak there here's how many people in
the united states are dying today here's
how many people worldwide are dying we
would be panic every year about the flu
now by all available information
coronavirus is more deadly than the flu
the question is by what multiple so is
it a multiple of 10 is it multiple of 20
is a multiple of four
we don't really know at this point but
suffice it to say the de media attention
combined with lack of information and
repetition of the same conflicting
information over and over as making
people feel very uneasy this is being
reflected in the market so this morning
these stock futures had already dumped
over the weekend and finally that
materialized the early morning trading
the sp500 saying 7% shortly after
opening the Dow Jones Industrial Average
credit as much as 2,000 points before it
clawed back a little bit the Dow
actually had to be shut down I mean the
shut down the Dow for 15 minutes they
shut down the stock market for 15
minutes to allow people to sort of
regain their their bearings with reality
the stock market has basically stayed
the same since then it dropped briefly
the early morning trading over the
weekend the Dow Jones Industrial Average
was about basically 25,000 hours at
24,000 990 2.36 it dumped immediately
like in the opening minutes all the way
down to below twenty four thousand so
dumped two thousand points in the
opening minutes of the stock market it
paused for 15 minutes it dumped a little
bit more and then there was sort of a
slight recovery it would not be a shock
if by the end of the day there was
another dump because the bottom line is
the people who are investing in
short-term trading are not looking at
this market and feeling that the market
is is being quieted according to the
Washington Post the force freeze was a
sign of unprecedented volatility for
Wall Street I made the most turbulent
trading in recent memory
another 15-minute ho will be triggered
if the S&P 500's losses hit the 13
percent threshold in the event of a 20%
decline markets would actually shut down
for the entire day now that is
speculative that the markets would would
dump that much that there'd be that much
for them now listen here's the reality
if you are investing over the long haul
that's actually a fantastic time to buy
but over the long haul not over the
short haul not for the next year not for
the next six months if you're investing
over the next 30 years now's a great
time to buy right you got a little bit
of a market discount but if you are
investing over the next two years or
five years and
who tells you they know what's gonna
happen over the next year is lying to
you
nobody knows what's gonna happen over
the next year because nobody has enough
information about coronavirus the
disruption of global supply lines
whether this thing is actually being
mitigated in China or the reports are
just going down whether there are
secondary infections available now there
are rumors that koban 19 actually has
two strains and that one strain is less
deadly and there's a second strain
that's more deadly and you can be
reinfected like we just don't know
enough at this point which is what you
are seeing in the markets and the fact
that there is no credible globally
coordinated response to this thing and
all you see are headlines about 15
million Italians being quarantined right
now that sort of stuff is gonna make
people pretty damned uneasy
we recommend bribed the chief financial
analyst at bank rate said the bull
markets 11 your birthday is today but
investors are not in a celebratory mood
with trading halted shortly after the
open as markets plunged the uncertain
economic impact of coronavirus continues
to grip markets with stocks commodities
and interest rates all dropping sharply
markets hate uncertainty there's a ton
of it currently in play that of course
is exactly right I mean the fact is that
Airlines I got two emails from separate
Airlines this morning I'm sure all the
airline's sent emails this morning about
what they are doing about coronavirus
pledging to bleach the entire insides of
planes basically they've used the the
bleach typically overnight in like the
lavatories but now they're talking about
bleaching entire planes they talk about
the sort of air sort of recirculation
they've been using on planes the filters
they've been using on planes to get
coronavirus out of the air if God forbid
somebody on the planes has grown virus
and sort of testing protocols they have
in place for fever and all the rest of
the sort of stuff the travel industry is
taking a bath just taking an absolute
bath right the US government has already
recommended that nobody go on a cruise
so that means that the cruise industry
is basically shut down the airline
industry is basically going to shut down
over the next several weeks you're going
to see people canceling trips on mass I
would be very surprised if over the next
few months you don't see the
cancellation of them maybe over the next
couple of weeks of major sporting events
because of local concerns about the
spread of corona virus the economy is
gonna grind to a halt and the question
is going to be how long the economy
grinds to a halt for right which sectors
of the economy are hardest hit now the
the Dow Jones Industrial Average in the
S&P 500 dumping part of that also has to
do with a major oil war that is going on
between the Saudis and the and the
Russians so the commodities market is
taking a dump people are rushing to
Treasuries but the problem is
that as you rested Treasuries and the
interest rates go down that is not
actually spurring people to borrow money
from the government the government the
Fed has been lowering its rate lowering
its rate lowering its rate who wants to
expand their business in the middle of
what could be a prolonged recession I
will get to more of this in just one
second again none of this is to spread
panic because I keep saying like we just
don't know enough to panic at this point
but it is to say that there is
justifiable concern today and unless we
see more information emerge relatively
soon from the from the state local and
federal government unless we start
seeing some real answers as to as to
these rates this uncertainties gonna
prevail and that's not unreasonable it's
not a reasonable for uncertainty to
prevail again this doesn't mean go panic
buy everything off the shelves at Costco
it doesn't mean that everyone around you
is gonna get coronavirus your risk is
still relatively low but to not take
this seriously would be tomfoolery and
by the way for all those Democrats who
are saying that Republicans were calling
this a hoax that is not true well
Republicans were saying was a hoax is
blaming the son Trump this is not
Trump's fault it is hard to see how
given the resources at his disposal the
reaction could've been appreciably
different from the federal government
Trump's rhetoric could have been
appreciably different that would've been
helpful but in terms of what the federal
government has done and continues to do
the federal government just approved
over eight billion dollars in
coronavirus spending over the weekend so
I'm a hard pressed to see what Trump
should be doing that he is not doing at
this point other than shut up we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first you know now would be a good time
to buy some life insurance man this is a
dark show today really really dark but
here's the reality of your responsible
human being should always have life
insurance you've got a family you should
have life insurance you never know
what's gonna be around the corner is it
a car or is it coronavirus who the hell
knows but what you do know is that at
some point something bad could happen
this is why you ought to have life
insurance your family is taken care of
in case god forbid something happens to
you this is why you should go check out
policy genius today policy genius makes
finding the right life insurance a
breeze in minutes you can you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could save
fifteen hundred bucks or more a year by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance if your
life doesn't play out exactly as you
expect it do not get discouraged be
prepared for
with life insurance in just a few
minutes you can find your best price and
apply at policy genius.com that's policy
genius comm policy genius because we'll
always get the future wrong better to
get life insurance right and be a
responsible human being policy
genius.com again policy genius icon now
the reason that I am not speculating too
much on where I think this is gonna go
is I don't think speculation is
supremely useful if I were to speculate
I do not think that hundreds of
thousands of people in the United States
ends up dead from coronavirus I do not
think that you're gonna see you know a
the stand I don't think that's best
available information that's speculating
on the best available information but
again taking those sort of safe
procedures makes some sense what's
happening right now is also coronavirus
is having some systemic impacts it's
basically a trigger mechanism for what
is happening in the stock market under
lay underlying the stock market anyway
the European economy has been weak for
years the Chinese economy has been
overblown for years and now that supply
chains are being disrupted and demand is
going down you're starting to see the
economy tumble into a recession that
honestly is not completely unpredictable
like literally every eight to ten years
the United States goes into some sort of
recession this one is not Trump's fault
it really is not and the Fed is not
going to relieve this anybody who thinks
that the Federal Reserve is going to fix
all of this is not telling you the truth
the Federal Reserve lowering interest
rates is not going to jog the economy
people are not spending because there is
too much uncertainty because supply
lines have been disrupted because demand
is going down if you actually want to
jog the economy right now there are only
a couple of things you can do stimulus
packages by the way are also not gonna
work government spending is not gonna
work the only thing that can be done
really is you got to solve the
underlying issues and that means get
more information about coronavirus as
soon as humanly possible once that
happens then things can go back to a
level of stasis people in the in the
media are saying throw money at it
stimulus packages will solve this thing
stimulus packages did not solve the
global recession of 2007 at 2008 let's
solve the global recession of 2000 2000
2007 2008 was basically time right that
some of the bailouts helped for sure in
terms of short-term recovery but the
stimulus package in my opinion it did
not have a markedly appreciable effect
on the increase in the economy in fact
government spending and increased
taxation probably slowed the recovery
which is why you ended up with the most
prolonged recovery in American history
because it was very slow and steady all
the way so basically the
point but meanwhile things are being
complicated because oil prices are
tumbling too normally again when the
stock market starts to tumble people
rush to invest in commodities like oil
but oil prices are also tumbling because
the Saudis went to the Russians and they
said guys we need to pump a little bit
more we need to do that in order to ease
global global economic tensions global
economic fears we need to make it
cheaper for people to go to work cheaper
for people to travel and the Russian
said no and the sadi said well fine
screw you we'll just I'll pump you and
so the Saudis have been undercutting the
Russian prices in terms of oil oil
prices tumbled into the $30 range after
Saudi Arabia and Russia deadlocked over
production The Saturdays had been
pushing for a cut in output to prop up
prices rather sorry I got that wrong the
Saudis wanted to prop up the prices a
little bit to prop up the oil industry
but did a reversal when Russia balked
and decided instead to flood the market
with hundreds of thousands of additional
barrels per day at a steep discount the
Russians were attempting to undercut the
American fracking industry at least in
part and the Saudis were like okay you
want to play this game we'll play this
game and the Saudis decided to lower the
oil prices fairly dramatically cheap oil
is one thing super cheap oil is another
said John Kilduff of again capital the
stock market is looking at the oil price
plunge as a canary in the coalmine of a
disinflationary one-two punch driven
partly by cratering demand for
transportation fuels and a wanton price
war among the major oil producers that
could result in big losses for oil
producers across the planet so you are
seeing a radically radically duction
into man at the same time that in terms
of oil you're seeing a radical increase
in supply as I say the energy industry
is about to take a major is about to
take a major hit the travel industry is
gonna take a bath public events are
gonna take a major bath so we're looking
at some very serious issues and not all
of those are driven by coronavirus part
of that is driven by excessive
government spending in the West that has
been really debt related I mean it's
easy to say that the United States you
just take out that but who exactly is
going to be buying up that debt is there
tons of appetite for American debt given
the slowing of the American economy
there's more appetite for the debt right
now than there is for stock market
pricing but you really have to
incentivize people to take the debt
which is why I would not be surprised to
see president Trump start to push
negative interest rates the idea that we
are gonna start actually paying people
to borrow from the US government it
meanwhile confusion spreads in Italy
Israel as
is trying to lock down 16 million people
is why I say it's not about Trump it is
not about the United States per se this
is a global worry issue according to the
Washington Post Italy on Sunday launched
a complicated and urgent plan to
restrict the movement of roughly 16
million people a measure that unleash
confusion about how it could be enforced
and whether it be enough to slow the
spread of the coronavirus the plan to
lock down large swathes of the north was
the first major attempt by democracy
during the coronavirus crisis to
radically halt the routines of daily
life an effort that will have
significant impacts on civil liberties
but in the hours before and after the
measure became a while people continue
to stream out of the northern hubs of
Milan and Venice on trains and planes
for southern Italy or elsewhere in
Europe Sunday provided the first glimpse
of a coronavirus locked down
european-style a test of how the open
border spirit of the continent might
change as countries grapple with the
scale and risk of the disease Italy is
not trying to completely lock down
movement like China did but even limited
movement risks further spreading the
virus also countries in Europe are
trying to shut their borders to one
another they are very much afraid that
human migration is going to is going to
spread this thing now here's a piece of
good news a piece of good news that the
virus is spread in China is apparently
slowing China on Sunday announced only
40 new cases of coronavirus and 22
additional cases of deaths the problem
is you can never really trust the
Chinese government to be honest with you
about this China's propaganda arm the
the media and China they've been trying
to suggest that Jinping did a wonderful
job at this whole coronavirus thing oh
yeah you mean except for the first six
weeks where you were like imprisoning
everybody talking about it and
preventing everybody from effectuating
effective travel bans like what would
that be the part where you did a great
job where was the part where we were
welding people inside their houses daily
new infections in China had dropped into
double digits Friday again according to
The Washington Post for the first time
since figures began coming out in
January as usual the toll in China was
concentrated in who by province the
outbreaks epicenter 21 of the reported
deaths were in who by 36 of the new
cases were in its capital city of Wuhan
but even in Wuhan Chinese officials have
been signaling optimism the Communist
Party boss said there on Friday he would
begin a citywide thankfulness education
campaign to encourage people to show
their appreciation for the leadership
because in a commie country you can just
force people to clap even if those
leaders were responsible for the spread
of death inside your country China's
infections total about eighty one
thousand one thirty one hundred deaths
inside the country there's still almost
thousand coronavirus patients remaining
in the hospital five thousand of them
have been deemed critical so it could be
that that death toll raises dramatically
right at five thousand people are
critical let's say half of those people
end up dying god forbid then you end up
with initial 2500 deaths on your hands
which is a pretty massive increase in
the death rate even in in Wuhan yeah
Europe is trying to figure out what to
do there's a lot of talk about closing
borders meanwhile the government in the
United States is stepping up its
coronavirus responses the US case is top
of 500 according to the post
government's intensified their efforts
on Sunday to combat the global spread of
the novel coronavirus uncertainty
continued to permeate the response
effort amid muddled directives from the
Trump administration and reports of some
patients unable to access testing it is
true that the testing in the United
States has been incredibly lackluster it
has been late and it's a real problem
because we don't have information on the
levels of spread based on the lack of
testing a virus stricken cruise-ship
made its way to California to dock only
for Housing and Urban Development
Secretary ben Carson declined to discuss
the details of the federal response plan
during a national television interview
we're gonna get to the Trump
administration response in just one
second also of course we're gonna get to
the fact that Ted Cruz has
self-quarantine we've also seen
Representative Paul Gosar of Arizona
self-quarantine which by the way is the
responsible thing to do if you think
that you've been exposed to corona virus
and you shouldn't show up to the office
Michael moles you should probably
instead stay home that's a in any case
we will get to more of this in just one
second first it's all of this making it
hard for you to sleep I understand I get
it also I understand why you're not
sleeping if you have a small baby
because I have a small baby at home and
this means that I really do value my
bull and branch sheets these are the
safest most comfortable sheets in the
world and the only abetting loved by
three US presidents I'll let you guess
who there are they're not that many who
are alive for a limited time you can get
bull and branches luxury flannel bedding
to keep you cool sleepers warm and
because they breathe keep you warm
sleepers cool betting is one of those
things you don't wanna skimp on because
you are going to be crawling between
those sheets every night so why exactly
would you save money there instead of
getting I mean first of all you will say
money as opposed to sheets of similar
quality via Boleyn branch but also why
would you like skimp there and go down
and pick up like a $20 sheet that's
gonna be like a tarp and make you sweats
can be terrible instead get the best
sheets on the market I'm talking about
bull and branch
shipping is always free you can try them
out for 30 nights risk-free
and right now you got 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
comm with promo code ben shapiro got 50
bucks off at bull and branch comm promo
code ben shapiro spell bol and branch
comm promo code ben shapiro restrictions
may apply see bull and branch comm for
details you're on better sleep quality
you need better sheets go check them out
right now
bull and branch comm for all of the
details okay so the Trump administration
response originally the Trump
administration was criticized for trying
to run all this through Pence's office
now the fact of the matter is that the
Trump administration does need to be
very coordinated in its response because
the markets are reacting to the Trump
administration the media are reacting to
the Trump administration and again it is
it is the blanket media coverage that is
driving a lot of this as I say if there
were blanket media coverage about the
flu every year there would be if not a
similar level of panic because the
flowing quite as dangerous as
coronavirus by all available indicators
there would still be a significantly
higher level of concern about the flu if
we covered flu the same way that we
cover corona virus with that said corona
virus did breakout at CPAC according to
the Washington Post a growing sense of
concern and uncertainty about the reach
of the novel coronavirus
has begun to take hold in the White
House after an attendee at a recent
political conference where President
Trump spoke tested positive for Cova 19
the disease caused by the virus
Trump was photographed shaking hands
with Matt's lap the chairman of the
American Conservative Union he confirmed
he had been in direct contact with the
infected man during CPAC he also says
that he feels fine meanwhile senator Ted
Cruz apparently met the person who is
affected by corona virus at CPAC as well
and released a statement saying that he
briefly interacted with this person he
said he consulted with medical
authorities from Houston Health
Department the Harris County Public
Health Department the Center for Disease
Control and Prevention the Department of
Health and Human Services and he also
spoke with vice president pence leader
McConnell and Mark meadows the new
president's new chief of staff's the
president he says not experiencing any
symptoms I feel fine and healthy given
the interaction was ten days ago that
the average incubation period is five to
six days the interaction was less than a
minute and I have no current symptoms
medical authorities have advised me that
the odds of transmission were extremely
low but I don't know buns danced of
caution because of how frequently I
interact with constituents is part of my
job and to give everyone peace of mind
I've decided to remain at my home in
Texas this week until a full 14 days
have passed since the CPAC interaction
that is the smart thing to do that is
sort
the responsible thing to do and the fact
that Cruz is being criticized for that
is ridiculous people who are saying well
you know Cruz and the rest of the
Republicans they were saying that this
is a hoax no again the part that
everyone was saying was a hoax was not
the corona virus itself what everybody
was saying was a hoax was the media
coverage focused on Trump as though
Trump were responsible for coronavirus
as opposed to the Chinese government
that the Trump administration was
responsible for the stock market drop as
opposed to you know the global economy
coming to a screeching halt that's the
part that was a hoax
no I'm not aware of anybody who
suggested that coronavirus itself was a
hoax and again I think everybody is if
not it you know the panic I think is too
much but overt concern is not too much
and the fact is that we do have to spend
more money on on converting medical ICU
beds on preparing for the possibility of
serious outbreak here in the United
States now with all of this said there
are experts who are sort of giving
conflicting messages and this is why
it's hard to tell exactly what's going
on dr. Tom Ingoldsby of Johns Hopkins
University he runs their public health
department over there he says listen
we're actually fairly well prepared for
a corona virus outbreak here in the
United States we have good public health
facilities I was surprised to see that
report I didn't know what's coming and
it is true that the u.s. when you when
you measure capabilities up and down in
public health healthcare surveillance
the u.s. is better prepared than any
other country okay so that is a good
thing to keep in mind it is also a good
thing to keep in mind you know Surgeon
General says listen the average age of
people who are dying is 80 plus so yes
this is mostly dangerous to people in
nursing homes so if you're gonna have
contacts at somebody in a nursing home
don't go to a public event and then go
to a nursing home right don't be a
person who has a grandmother who's 90
and you talk with her every week and she
comes over your house and then you do
like out in public all the time that's
what the Surgeon General was saying and
this is correct we know that the average
age of people who are dying from
coronavirus is 80 plus we know that the
average age of people who are needing
medical care in advanced medical care is
60 plus and so what we're telling folks
is that if you're in an at-risk group
its meaning you're elderly and or you
have comorbidities heart disease lung
disease your immunosuppressed for
whatever reason that you should be
taking extra precautions not to put
yourself in a situation where you may be
exposed
yeah and that of course is the
responsible thing to do Democrats and
Republicans are basically saying that
the public reaction
is overblown concern is warranted panic
is not Andrew Cuomo the governor of New
York is saying the same thing the Trump
is saying it's just that he's not
getting blamed the same way the Trump is
getting blamed but just let's pause for
a moment on how serious it is because
I'm afraid that the fear is actually
outpacing the facts and we're fighting
the virus but we're also fighting this
this anxiety and people have to think
that they step back deep breath and
actually understand what we're looking
at okay now with that said again
everybody is taking safety precautions
Princeton University in the last couple
of hours issued a notice to students
that people should be encouraged to stay
home after Spring Break they shouldn't
even come back after Spring Break that
they should just stay home and they're
gonna make sure that students can still
fulfill their their class requirements
may be the upside of all of this is
everybody goes to online education which
wouldn't be the world's worst thing I
mean I can make up for obviously the
cost of all of this again one of the
problems here is that when when the
Trump administration responds when
President Trump responds because he
speaks in superlatives and now would be
a time for measured response
superlatives are not a good idea so
President Trump tweeted out we have a
perfectly coordinated and fine-tuned
plan at the White House for our attack
on coronavirus we move very early to
close borders to certain areas which was
a godsend VP is doing a great job the
fake news media is doing everything
possible to make us look bad sad okay
two things can be true ones the media
will jump on anything they perceive
Trump is doing wrong they did the same
thing to george w bush over hurricane
katrina that is 100% true it is also
true that suggesting that the plan is
perfectly coordinated and fine-tuned in
the middle of people feeling like we
can't even get testing done that is not
smart politics the President of the
United States should convene a massive
conference video conference so people
aren't often on each other all the
governors the President of the United
States the heads of HHS and Homeland
Security and they should lay out some
procedures for what exactly the federal
government would like to see done in
terms of public events in terms of
public gatherings in terms of testing
procedures and protocols in terms of
advice to give to the public the
administration and states at this point
should be speaking with one voice and
how they deal with all of this that's
not just me saying this okay that is
that is experts on this stuff or saying
this sort of stuff dr. Scott Gottlieb
the former FDA Commissioner under
President Trump right he's taking this
stuff very seriously he says listen
have to take some really serious
measures here like serious serious
measure so we're gonna see economic
slowdown we're going to see public
events shut here is the dr. Scott
Gottlieb the former FDA Commissioner by
the way nobody that doesn't mean that
huge numbers of people are gonna die the
whole point here is to mitigate the
effect here is dr. Gottlieb well I think
no state and no city wants to be the
first to basically shut down their
economy but that's what's gonna need to
happen states and cities are gonna have
to act in the interest of the national
interest right now to prevent a broader
epidemic that's down their economy you
mean close businesses close large
gatherings close theaters canceled
events I think we need to think about
how do we provide assistance to the
people of these cities who are going to
be hit by hardship as well as the
localities themselves to try to give
them an incentive to do this okay and
again this Scott Gottlieb should be
called in by the president he should
help coordinate this thing right now we
have when we say we have to have a
coordinated response that coordinated
response has to be made public because
the problem is like Ben Carson shouldn't
be on TV being asked these questions so
Ben Carson who's the head of the Housing
and Urban Development Department why is
he being asked about America's response
about the federal government's response
to a cruise ship on which coronavirus
has appeared off the coast of California
Ben Carson is heading the housing
department what the hell does he have to
say about coronavirus outbreaks here's
Ben Carson president met with the CEOs
of the major cruise ship companies
yesterday and they are coming up with a
plan within 72 hours of that meeting
ships docking tomorrow the plan will be
in place by that time but I don't I
don't want to preview the plan right now
shouldn't you be able to do that I think
I think it needs to all come from a
solitary source we shouldn't have 16
people saying what the plan is okay this
is correct we shouldn't have 16 people
saying with the plan and so why is dr.
Carson being booked on this week you
know he's gonna be asked about this
stuff I mean and then the media go with
well they don't have a plan what maybe
they do have a plan but Ben Carson isn't
the one speaking to it he's the head of
the Housing and Urban Development
Department is like asking Betsy the Voss
what the plans are for cruise ships
she's the head of the Education
Department like the media expect there
to be a great answer here there's no
great answer here now again I don't
think that the Trump administration is
botching this thing
I just think that the messaging is
pretty screwed up and I think that we
actually need a coordinated response
with an actual plan and governors and
states are not doing a great job either
again the City of Seattle right jay
Inslee is the governor of Washington
State why exactly did governor Inslee
not shut down comic-con in the state in
the state of Washington in Seattle why
did the LA Marathon proceed a pace in
Los Angeles like what why are big but
local leaders have capacity to hear and
they're not doing any of this the
Democrats by the way are also doing this
routine like the Democrats are
suggesting that President Trump is
violating all norms that there's no plan
here Bernie Sanders says he's gonna keep
going ahead with his rallies Bernie
Sanders has said that he's not gonna
stop his rallies Trump says he's even go
ahead with his rallies meanwhile
universities are saying we don't want
the liability of all of this so with all
of this mixed-up information that is
emerging how do you expect people to
feel super secure right as the as the
the person who's gonna bear the brunt of
that is President Trump he is he's the
he is the President of the United States
the President of the United States bears
the brunt of all of this fairly or
unfairly I don't think that the Trump
administration has botched this in any
serious way but I do think that now it's
time to up the ante the president is
being politically irresponsible if he
does not come up with a coordinated an
extremely public plan that doesn't
involve him tweeting things like this
within the last few hours so last year
37 American 37,000 Americans died from
the common flu it averages between
27,000 and seventy thousand per year
nothing is shut down life and the
economy go on at this moment there are
546 confirmed cases of corona virus with
22 deaths think about that okay
what why why is that part of your
coordinated response is that part of the
coordinated response to go on Twitter
and say this kind of stuff like well you
literally handed messaging over to Mike
Pence and now you're seizing messaging
back in order to militate against me
look Trump is a counter puncher we all
know this this means that the media
jabbing at Trump is going to elicit
counter punches from Trump but that's
not going to help Trump it's not gonna
help people feel more secure it's not
gonna help people feel more calm in all
of this let Anthony foutch II speak
about right doctor foul G from the
National Institute of Health like he's
at least being honest about all of this
stuff and he knows what he's talking
about first of all he is happy to debunk
media falsehood so they were saying that
doctor foul had been muzzled by
Trump administration dr. FAQ she said of
course I'm not muzzled I'm right here
talking to you on CBS what are you
talking about I think a lot of people
are very interested in the relationship
between the scientists and the
administration right and specifically if
President Trump says something like at
the beginning of every like we think we
have it under control you're in the room
were you able to push back of course
some people have been worried that
you've been muzzled
I'm not muzzled because I'm talking to
exactly your right here okay
hey and that's true also foul shooter
honest enough to say yeah there were
some early missteps in the testing we
don't have enough information at this
point to make solid calls here is
vouching explaining can anybody who
needs a test get a test now the fact is
the tests are out there there was a
misstep early on with regard to the test
namely a a technical difficulty but
right now about 1.1 million tests are
out there now okay so now he is he's
saying he's saying we're getting this on
track I let Falchi talk let Falchi help
set the policy let your experts at the
policy Trump he's not reassuring anybody
no national address is gonna do anything
last time he gave a national press
conference on coronavirus the stock
market tanked the president needs to
step aside right now he needs to let
pence lead the effort if pence wants to
kick it to Falchi he should let Falchi
do this if he wants to kick it to Scott
Gottlieb dr. Gottlieb and bring him back
in let him do this the dumbest thing
that Trump could do right now is try and
seize control of this messaging it is
not going to is not going to bode well
for him in fact politically speaking
it's almost a perfect storm for Joe
Biden the reason it's almost a perfect
storm for Joe Biden is a tanking economy
is horrible for the incumbent president
presidents do not win during a tanking
economy and two if you are looking for
reassurance and the president doesn't
provide it and then Joe Biden whose
entire pitch is back to normal I'm gonna
put together back the Obama team you
know me I've been here for a long time
I'm you're reassuring all the uncle but
that's actually a really good pitch for
Joe Biden in the face of all of this so
Trump's vulnerabilities are being
exposed by that by his response to the
coronavirus that doesn't mean that Trump
loses the election it does mean that a
coordinated serious response with
coordinated serious people is necessary
and by the way there's a significant
possibility than three months from now
we have more information the fears have
abated a little bit
the economy picks back up and Trump is
fine but the current response from the
Trump administration and not even the
administration from Trump himself is
insufficient and very very politically
stupid very politically stupid now again
that doesn't alleviate the media from
their responsibilities of jumping with
both feet on Trump even before he had
done anything wrong they were gonna do
that in any case but just because
somebody is shooting at you doesn't mean
you should put a gun to your own head
and blow your face off like that's just
not a smart political strategy as it
turns out okay we're gonna get to the
2020 race in just one second but first
the Daily wires own Andrew Klavan has
released the second entry and has
another Kingdom trilogy the nightmare
feast
Austin Lively once just an out of lock
Hollywood screenwriter is now a chosen
hero caught between two worlds and dual
question both LA and the magical
medieval world Galliano experience the
fantasy adventure that captivated and
entertained thousands of listeners
despite Michael moles doing the reading
you've heard the podcast now get the
book today over an Amazon book is really
fantastic Drew's a really talented dude
gonna have some time on your hands while
you're sitting Oh trying to avoid
coronavirus so pick up a copy of Drew's
new book over at Amazon today meanwhile
time is running out to get 25% off all
daily wire memberships with coupon code
never socialist so hurry before the deal
ends just like the Bernie Sanders
campaign daily where members get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now
exclusive election insight op-eds from
yours truly
daily wire members also get to ask us
questions during backstage and our new
all-access tear allows you to join in
live online q and A's with me and the
other hosts along with all of this of
course you have the magnificent the
irreplaceable the singular left this
year's tumbler if you haven't already
download the daily where apps you get
all of our great content on the go again
that is 25% off on daily wire
memberships for all plans using coupon
code never socialists so head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe this is
the last week we will be giving you this
offer so act now before you regret it
that is daily wire calm slash subscribe
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so again as I say this is a this is
a perfect storm for Joe Biden Joe Biden
was just on Lawrence O'Donnell moments
ago about Trump and coronavirus fall out
he said I wish you'd just be quiet
I really mean it that's an awful thing
to say about a president but I wish he'd
be quiet just let the experts speak I
hate to say when Joe Biden is right Joe
Biden is correct the president is not
making people like you honestly do you
feel calmer when Trump speaks about
coronavirus like do you feel coming I
don't feel calmer do you feel calmer I
feel calmer when I hear Falchi I heard
comon when I hear Gottlieb when I when I
hear people I think know what they are
talking about I feel calmer when I hear
President Trump mouth off about this
stuff I don't feel calmer what that
means is that anyone who pledges to calm
fears is going to be in a politically
advantageous position and if it's chaos
all the way down if there's a feeling of
chaos leading into the election like
Trump's biggest asset was that as
chaotic as he is his human being the
feeling leading up to the election was
not one that the United States was in
chaos based on the stock market based on
coronavirus based on the election itself
I mean what happens if coronavirus is
still affecting the population we got a
boat in November are we all just gonna
vote absentee like house exactly that
gonna work right if the feeling is
generalized Kass and Trump is an agent
of cast that is not going to benefit him
politically which is why it behooves him
to run a smart campaign and to be a
smart president and to simply back off
and shut up okay this is a time when
when your Twitter account is not helping
things I know this ain't gonna be
popular with a lot of my conservative
listeners who love Trump's Twitter and
who may feel they feel correctly the
coronavirus is overblown I've written
two pieces in the last week about how I
think that the risks of coronavirus are
not nearly as great as the media have
been making them out to be but with that
said reassurance is the name of the game
politically and also in terms of public
policy if people feel reassured then
they are going to be more responsible in
their handling of this stuff they aren't
gonna panic by medical masks from Amazon
for 100 bucks a pop right they're not
gonna be looking for reams of toilet
paper as though nobody's ever gonna wipe
their butt again reassurance is the name
of the game here and that is why you
know that that is why this is it's a
boon to Biden meanwhile speaking of that
2020 Democratic presidential race Bernie
is basically out of this thing right
Bernie has there's an election coming up
in Michigan the Michigan primaries are
coming up very soon and Bernie is really
heavily in the Michigan primaries which
has led Bernie to attack Joe Biden
Bernie says listen I'm not dropping out
no matter what right I'm sticking around
even if I lose Michigan I'm sticking
around that's a problem for the
Democratic Party because there may be a
lot of Biden supporters I mean Bernie
supporters who don't show up in the
election if Biden acts all ticked off
all the way to the convention how
serious is that how damaging and would
you consider dropping out no I certainly
would not consider dropping out you know
Chris media asks you is this state or
that state life with death I was outside
at I was at New Hampshire we won
California the largest state in this
country we are winning among Latino
voters big time we are one many winning
among young people okay and Bernie is
also wining over Super Tuesday and is
bad news for the Democratic Party
internally the Democratic Party is still
rift over the over the the Biden versus
Bernie split and the consolidation
behind by any Biden is not alleviating
the concerns of the Bernie people who
feel like he got jobs like he was about
to get the nomination and then the
entire party establishment swiveled
behind Bernie here is here's Bernie
whining over Super Tuesday the
establishment put a great deal of
pressure on Pete Budaj on a me Club
which are who ran really aggressive
campaigns why know both of them they
work really really hard but suddenly
right before Super Tuesday they
announced their withdrawal if they had
not withdrawn from the race before Super
Tuesday which is kind of a surprise to a
lot of people I suspect we would have
won in Minnesota we won one in Maine we
would one in Massachusetts the turnout
may have been a little bit different the
ongoing consolidation behind Biden
continues as well Kamala Harris has now
endorsed Joe Biden she says that she
believes in Joe which is weird since he
prevented he tried to prevent her I
heard from taking a bus to her
integrated public school if it had not
been for for the rest of the government
then Joe Biden would have stopped Kamala
Harris from being a senator apparently
but now she's a big fan of Joe Biden
weird how times change that quickly I
have decided that I am with great
enthusiasm I'm going to endorse Joe
Biden for president of you know
States I believe in gentlemen I really
believe in him and I have known him for
a long time one of the things that we
need right now is we need a leader who
really does care about the people and
who can therefore unify the people and I
believe Joe can do that ok well that's
weird because I'm old enough to remember
when Pamela Harris had this to say I was
actually very it was hurtful to hear you
talk about the reputations of two United
States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country and
it was not only that but you also worked
with them to oppose busing meanwhile
Hillary Clinton is still sounding off
about Bernie Sanders like slamming him
over and over and over
ripping Bernie over to lack of 2016
support that's an ongoing threat to the
Democratic Party because the fact is
that the Bernie bros could simply not
show up for Joe Biden either his failure
and the behavior of a lot of his top
aides and certainly many of his
supporters up to the convention at the
convention and even up to election day
was not helpful
I had thought we would unify that's what
we'd always done before and that's what
I expected so again the split inside the
Democratic Party is not going to be
alleviated in anytime soon
the the question in the 2020 election
going forward is going to be about
whether it's a referendum on Trump I've
been saying this for years if the
election is a referendum on Trump he's
in trouble if the election is a
referendum on the Democrats the
Democrats lose Trump's assumption was
that it would be a referendum on the
Democrats he'd go in with a solid
economy people would feel good about the
country polls we're showing this just a
month ago the assumption was that if
we're Bernie Sanders he could make it
pretty easily a referendum on Bernie
Sanders that's true if Joe Biden is the
nominee if the economy is still in
trouble if Trump continues to
demonstrate chaotic leadership in the
face of something like coronavirus it
will be a referendum on Trump it will
not go well
watch for the polls in the next week and
a half to reflect this and now again we
are super early okay it is it is March
okay there's a lot of time until
November I would not be surprised if the
polling in the next week between Biden
and and Trump shows Biden up it with
there
very large numbers now again I think a
lot of that will alleviate as time goes
on as coronavirus alleviates as we get
more information but now is a time I've
been saying for a while Republicans
cannot be sanguine about President Trump
winning re-election on the back of his
chaotic campaigning he has to run a
disciplined campaign and people have
been like well you know he didn't run
into soup Lindh campaign last time it
worked out fine right and and doing it
once does not mean that it is duplicate
ball lots of things happen once the
question is whether the lightning
strikes twice
don't make luck your business strategy
for the Trump campaign discipline
discipline somebody needs to get in the
president's here right now and tell them
to stop tweeting about flu let your
people do their jobs when you let your
people do their jobs people feel secure
and then we're willing to overlook all
of the other silliness --is that have
happened but right now would be a time
for discipline particularly message
discipline when people are so deeply
worried and again I think that some of
the I think the panic is overblown but I
think worry is appropriate in the face
of a complete lack of information and
the amount of chaos that is going on not
domestically in America right not just
driven by the US media going on globally
right we are seeing panic that is
happening all across Europe in Asia okay
that has nothing to a trump it has
nothing to with US media okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
I over the weekend reading some sci-fi
I've been sort of on a sci-fi kick
there's a fun series from a guy named
Pierce Brown the first the first book in
this series is called red rising and it
basically the the basic premise of the
book it's it's sort of like a cross
between Hunger Games and get in Game of
Thrones which is a fairly you know good
recommendation the basic premise of the
book is that on Mars there's a group of
people who are kept in slavery in order
to mine and provide the resources
necessary in order to power a society
they don't even know exists above them
and finally one of these people escapes
the kind of slave society and elevates
and rank it's it the hope the hope book
is supposed to be based on Greek notions
of or Spartan notions rather of sort of
divisions of society that there are the
people who are best tasked to lead
there's people who are best tasked to
follow and and why that is anti
democracy the book is fun and it's and
it's easy to read and it's kind of
I can check out red rising if you're
into sort of dystopian sci-fi and again
it's kind of a cross between The Hunger
Games and a little bit Game of Thrones
and it's fun
check it out red rising by by Pierce
brown other things that I like so one of
the things that I love most is the fact
that socialists in the United States are
happy to live off the benefits of
capitalism Carlos Mazda who's just a
garbage ape house Mazda you'll remember
is the person who tried to get steven
crowder kicked off of youtube for using
terms for gay people that I would not
use okay and Carlos Mazda was being made
fun of by a comedian and decided he
didn't like with the comedian said and
so he led a national campaign to get
steven crowder kicked off of youtube
leaving the leadership of his then
publication Vox Media to try and kick
steven crowder off of youtube while
claiming that they weren't actually in
favor of censorship despite the fact
that Steven didn't actually violate any
of YouTube's policies and YouTube
instead demonetised Crowder on the basis
of not violating any of their policies
ok well now it turns out the caller
Carlos Mazda he launched his own channel
it is a communist channel that's about
how he is a commie there's only one
problem
he is extremely extremely rich if Mazda
wants to start eating the rich reports
the New York Post he may have to begin
with his own family through his clan the
Millennial firebrand is connected to
multiple florida mega mansions a 7.1
million dollar pan on the Upper West
Side purchased under an LLC and a yacht
buy luxury boat maker Don Z as it turns
out the most ardent socialists in
American society are very often the
people who have never had to experience
socialism because mommy and daddy made
lots of money so mommy and daddy will
just let them live off the trust fund
while they talk about revolution Mazdas
mother Vivian Mazda was one of the first
employees an ultimate software a
florida-based behemoth that now employs
more than 5,000 people starting in 1990
as an office manager she ultimately rose
to become the group's chief people
officer in 2004 in addition to her a day
job Vivian Mazda also developed a very
close personal relationship with the
company's founder Scott share so closed
then independent assessment of the
company in 2016
cited the relationship as a corporate
governance concern the report said the
pair were believed to be more than just
coworkers and had a familial
relationship hmm
the two later became engaged the couple
has lived together for years share is a
de facto stepfather to Carlos according
to the New York Post public records show
that Vivian Scott Carlos and sister
Isabel all registered to vote in a five
bedroom eight bathroom waterfront palace
in Boca Raton the property sold
mm 18 for 11 million dollars 11 million
dollars but socialism guys he's real
he's an ardent commie he's an ardent
commies shirt his mother and stepfather
presumably would be the first kulaks to
go but he is an ardent communist Vivian
currently resides full-time in a 4.4
million dollar two-bedroom three-bath
luxury condo in Fort Lauderdale the same
LLC purchased a 7.1 million dollar condo
on the Upper West Side of Manhattan in
November 2017 while serving a CEO of
ultimate software sure was one of the
most handsomely compensated CEOs in the
country in 2015 he took home 38 point
three million dollars weird I don't see
carlos masa going to his stepdad who
presumably has provided him a basis of
support and being like you know it seems
to me that you aren't living the
principles of Marx sir it's not clear
how much Vivian and sure actively
support Mazdas lifestyle but evidence
suggests the family has been happy to
pitch in to help spread his socialist
message both Shira and Vivian Maserati
Lestat his comrades
at the end of Carlos his most recent
YouTube video basically he sounds like
the kind of child that they don't really
want to deal with and so they're like
okay we'll just give him a little bit of
money and he can go play commie over
here on YouTube and say he's a
trust-fund commie maza didn't respond to
multiple inquiries from the post but
then because of the enquiries he posted
a statement on Twitter he said my mom
and her fiance are very wealthy thanks
to a software company they started
together when I was a kid as a result
I've gotten to live a life of tremendous
privileged he said he acknowledged that
he always had a safety net should his
career to go south but insisted nobody
was bankrolling his effort okay well if
you have a safety net of you know tens
of millions of dollars then you can
afford to spend your life making useless
YouTube videos about how communism is
the greatest way of life of all so again
I love that we live in a country so
wealthy that the children of our
wealthiest people can be communists
that's really really exciting stuff
normally when they say the proletariat
are gonna rise workers of the world
unite you have to be a worker you know
not a lazy bum who relies on his parents
money for years on end and then gets a
job writing garbage at Vox media while
trying to oust other YouTube stars and
then makes stupid communist videos well
apparently taking money from mommy and
daddy so that I find fairly delicious so
well well done well done
Carlos maza speaking by the way of
socialists who are apparently happy to
take advantage of the benefits of
capitalism Elizabeth Warren appeared on
over the weekend I saw this one so
Elizabeth Warren has been worshipped by
members of the media if by nobody else
and she showed up on she showed up on
SNL with Kate McKinnon and it was
extremely extremely awkward not only did
I not accept money from billionaires I
got to give one a swirly on live TV
[Applause]
thank you thank you for not dead I'm
just in the Senate remember when they
did this for Ted Cruz I remember
remember when as don't worry SNL is just
comedy guys they're just comedy they are
not just a propaganda outlet on behalf
of the Democratic Party I do well the
reason that some things I like honestly
is because I do like it when they expose
number one how unfunny they are and
number two how politically motivated
they are so Elizabeth Maura it's amazing
she she just gets skunked how do you
appear on by the way how do you Peron
SNL and no one makes fun of the fact
that the funniest thing in American
politics is about you that you pretended
to be Native American for decades how is
that not even a joke how is that
possible okay so that brings us to the
end of things I like will skip some
things I hate today because listen
there's too much worry so let's end on
an up note I hope that you come back
later today with two additional hours
because there will be plenty of updates
I promise you otherwise we will see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike Rowe Romina hair and makeup is
by Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
Andrew Clayton
[Music]